salut je m'appelle fabien olicard dans
ce format nous analysons un point précis
en rapport avec le cerveau dans les
commentaires des épisodes précédents
vous m'avez proposé par les la
manipulation mentale ça tombe bien c'est
le sujet du jour bienvenue dans matière
grise
[Musique]
dans cet épisode vous allez vivre aux
quatre expériences expérience une les
experts expérience 2 les magiciens de la
manipulation expérience 3 c'est à vous
expérience quatre manipulateurs honnête
le tout avec la présence très appréciée
de et menace de la chaîne just lna
la manipulation mentale c'est un sujet
qui fascine qui fait peur qui séduit
mais qui ne laisse jamais indifférent
pouvons nous influencer les autres et
sommes nous condamnés à nous faire
manipuler toute notre vie nous allons
faire un tour dans nos cerveaux et nous
verrons même tout à l'heure comment les
illusionnistes vous font croire que la
magie existe pour de vrai
d'ailleurs est ce que le fait d'annoncer
les temps forts de la vidéo ça serait
pas déjà une manipulation voyons
maintenant comment détecter une
manipulation dans un contexte classique
première expérience sur la manipulation
mentale on va regarder une vidéo lna et
dans cette vidéo il ya ce jeune homme
qui ont envie de jeter lui il va en
discuter avec ses amis au téléphone je
te peut voir la vidéo soit attentive
après on va essayer de déterminer
ensemble d'abord toi quand est ce qu'il
ya eu manipulation quand il ya eu six ou
desquels qu'est-ce qu'il va peut-être pu
dire ou faire penser différemment parce
que la manipulation parfois à l'existant
on la voit pas et parfois on en voit là
où il y en a pas forcément c'est ça qui
m'intéresse c'est parti ouais ça y est
ouais bah je vais changer de télé bas la
mienne est morte se disant que je
l'avais
balawi je vais je vais sur le site là
ces mêmes sites que mes parents alors
ils achètent tous leurs trucs donc je
pense que je trouve je trouve quelque
chose quoi
oui allô bonjour bonjour monsieur alors
je vous appelle parce que je
souhaiterais acheter une nouvelle
télévision j'ai un budget de 350 euros
j'ai vu ce modèle à 399 ses impôts
dessus de mon budget mais bon elle
m'intéresse donc vraiment parler un peu
il est très bien monsieur oui le modèle
v12 je le vois ici alors sachez qu'il
vient en ce moment avec une offre sur un
système sont avec une réduction est ce
que ça vous intéresse ouais moi j'ai pas
spécialement besoin de systèmes sont en
plus je suis un peu serré niveau budget
donc non ça va allez merci mais tout est
très bien sachez que j'ai la carte de
fidélité qui me semble fait pour vous en
ce moment avec la carte de fidélité vous
pouvez payer en plusieurs fois et vous
pouvez aussi avoir un crédit à la
consommation grâce à notre partenaire
bancaire wen et non vraiment juste la
télé on enseignera merci beaucoup et
très bien monsieur finaliser la
transaction souhaitez vous que je vous
met l'extension de garantie avec sachez
qu'avec ses téléviseurs ça montre tout
de suite très vite si vous avez la
moindre panne et là sur cinq ans tout
est pris en charge elle c'est vrai que
ça risque de faire assez vite cher
ok ouais bon bah je vais prendre la
garantie ça marche écoutez très bien je
vous souhaite une bonne journée et à
bientôt ok merci beaucoup qu'est ce que
tu peux nous dire est ce que tu as vu
des manipulation flagrante ou des choses
qui te sambre est de la manipulation
parce que souvent quand on parle de
commerce en fait on se dit les vendeurs
à une magnifique en permanence plutôt
des techniques de vente tout à fait mais
des techniques de vente sont elles des
manipulations en fait moi je pars aussi
du principe que il ya quelque chose de
très honnêtes dans la vente c'est qu'on
sait que le vendeur veut vendre on
compte déjà un oeil vigilant ce qui est
quand même différente par rapport à une
conversation où quelqu'un te manipule
pour obtenir quelque chose de toi alors
que c'est pas annoncé dès le départ est
ce que tu as vu des manipulations de la
part toi de la vendeuse est en fait lui
revenait beaucoup sur le prix du coup
elle essaye de couleur rassurer et
surtout sur les nerfs le dernier le
dernier argument sur la garantie la
commande le comme lui était venue trois
quatre fois avec le fait de juger par un
bal de plus je trouve que c'est une
bonne chose qu'il a accepté l'extension
de garantie sans en parler plus toiture
de tu prends les extensions de garantie
non en fait tu vois elle elle utilise
vraiment un truc de manipulation qui est
une manipulation par la peur il n'a pas
encore acheté son produit qu'elle eût
dit que ouais mais quand il sera caché
ça risque de vite lui revenir cher pour
l'instant on n'en sait rien il ya
toujours une garantie constructeur nous
en france est obligatoire durant deux
ans en général les premières pannes
elles surviennent après cinq ans
d'utilisation donc de garantie
d'extension cinq ans elle sert pas à
grand chose et la majorité du temps
quand pays en ligne en carte bleue et la
vendeuse le sais très bien que tu as des
garanties en plus sur tes achats avec la
carte bleue les éléments d'un
travail sur la manipulation vous le
recommande
mais mais mais tout ça pour dire oui là
qu'on te propose un service en plus
surtout à la fin surtout qu'ils jouent
nus sur une peur ou un espoir ça vaut le
coup de prendre une vraie pause et
limite de reporter son achat pour y
réfléchir parce que c'est souvent 10 %
du prix de ton achat quand même cette
garantie voire 20% il ya d'autres
manipulations alors après les offres d
et noté
alors s'il ya des manipulations on est
tellement habitués qu'on les voit plus
399.99
comme prix
s'appelle 400 euros en vrai parce qu'en
vrai psychologiquement ça fonctionne lui
il avait un budget de 350 euros c'est ce
qu'il dit est ibon
399,99 voilà c'est un peu plus cher mais
celle ci elle me plait bien donc je vais
la prendre si elle avait été à 400 euros
c'est pas sûr qu'il aurait fait ce
franchissement de hors budget en fait
parce que quand même il aurait retenu le
chiffre quatre corps est beaucoup plus
d'impact donc même si tu sais exactement
quel est le vrai prix dans ta décision
de dépasser ton budget ça aide de rester
dans cette tranche là tu vois à 402
euros lure paru extrêmement cher dans la
sensation alors 4 399 il se dit bon
là aussi il ya une manipulation qui est
pas de la vendeuse directement et elle
qu'on veut qu'on voit moins venir à lui
à lui propose une bonne offre pour le
système soe la refuser est ce que c'est
une bonne chose mais du coup quand il
parle de ses potes il parle pas d'un
système sont effectivement
enfin en fait ça c'est une bonne chose
de l'avoir refusée parce qu'il sait
qu'il en a pas de besoin et puis il
avait ceux déjà ce budget serré le seul
truc qui est à retenir c'est que si par
contre celles l'avait intéressés ça vaut
le coup aussi de stopper son acte
d'achat ce moment là pour dire à temps
j'étais venu acheter une télé l'un
propose un système téléviseur plus un
système sont six à partir de maintenant
c'est ça que je veux ça vaut le coup que
j'arrête maintenant pour regarder ce que
fait la concurrence pour me renseigner
sur ces coins systèmes sont c'est quoi
mon besoin exactement le le truc à
retenir pour éviter la manipulation
c'est collecter des données en fait et
donc ça vaut le coup d'arrêtés les
processus tout de suite pour aller
collecter des données sur qu'est-ce qui
propose d'ailleurs de quoi j'ai vraiment
peu est-ce que je débloque un budget
pour ça ou pas et malheureusement tu
sais qu'on fait un acte d'achat après
les événements s'enchaînent yann a envie
d'obtenir ce qu'on était venu acheter
donc c'est très dur de rationaliser pour
dire stop quatuor donc effectivement tu
as raison il a bien fait de dire non en
l'occurrence après on lui a proposé la
carte de fidélité des magasins il a dit
non ça m'intéresse pas bonnes choses
mauvaises choses on a vu que ça fait dix
ans que ses parents ou là et qu'il a
l'air de pas mal connaître l'endroit
pour le coup
il aurait peut-être pu dire aux kings
déjà pu se renseigner pareil collecter
les données les cartes de fidélité elles
sont gratuites c'est peut-être aussi un
point de levier pour négocier quelque
chose tu vois de sa part s'en est dans
la manipulation mais juste dans en étant
dans l'optimisation peut-être il
pourrait négocier la livraison gratuite
ou une petite réduction un petit truc
comme ça en fait dès qu'il accepte
quelque chose de la part du vendeur bon
en fait tu te dis ok je viens d'accepter
donc la balance elle est comme ça
peut-être jeu polar est équilibré aussi
peuvent faire peut-être quelque chose en
retour et en refusant ne serait-ce que
d'écouter leur ba oui mais moi aussi
refusant de d'écouter la proposition
c'est ça aussi qui qui étire son seuil
de résistance à la manipulation et qui
va lui faire accepter après l'extension
de garantie qui est sûrement là une
connerie de l'accepter a ce moment la
côte voilà comment sur un événement de
vie quotidien on peut avoir plein
d'endroits de manipulation qu'on voit
pas venir certains qu'on pense des
jouets alors qu'en fait c'est une bêtise
c'est juste qu'on a peur donc on est sur
la défensive oh rien et d'autre en fait
après qu'on voit pas venir parce qu'on
atteint le seuil de résistance voilà
c'était la petite démonstration
[Rires]
vous le voyez la manipulation est
partout mais elle n'est pas forcément
chargé positivement ou négativement ce
qui la rend mauvaise est en général le
mensonge sur les données d'origine sur
les intentions ou encore le fait de
réduire le libre arbitre de la personne
ce qui veut dire que l'on peut manipuler
avec bienveillance c'est ce qu'on
appelle également l'influencent
maintenant six ans aucune manipulation
que je vous avoue que cette vidéo est
sponsorisé par mois
bonjour monsieur gaston du comptoir et
bonnes affaires et justement aujourd'hui
j'ai une bonne affaire pour
ce livre normalement et 400000 euros
j'ai aujourd'hui pour vous une offre
exceptionnelle
vu qu'il y avait juste là mais en fait
si 1000 euros je vous ai dit pas du tout
voiture devra à nouveau monsieur
aujourd'hui ce livre que je vous propose
cet art
c'est une offre qui dure cinq minutes je
connais cette technique en fait c'est le
faux mots que c'est dingue beurre de
rater des balles super je ne vous ai pas
tout dit avec cette offre exceptionnelle
et ce livre je rajoute un cadeau culture
désole d'une valeur de 4 118 euros c'est
un bijou un bon vieux mamdouh très cher
comme comme truc ça mais c'est aussi
plus de ce bisou sur le front une
piscine une piscine de valeur de 18
euros monsieur
pas très cher c'est une moto et un bisou
à 400 m du bal c'est très cher la
piscine à 18 euros les courses c'est une
pichenette
on met de l'eau et le gel inverse et
monsieur vous mettre sous le nez des
techniques de manipulation à ce même
fait un livre à l'époque sur le sujet je
vois exactement tous les processus et
les mécanismes devant nul que vous
mettez en place ça m'intéresse pas du
tout je vais plutôt pas avec ces gens
avec vous allez parler avec d'autres
gens c'est sûr que ça on peut citer nul
comment vous avez fait vous avez une
fête quoi ça parle pas ça c'est une
mémoire vous allez pouvoir vous
comprendre pour s'entraîner développer
si pour d'autres c'est un livre ou bas
il ya plein de technique de mémorisation
par exemple ou un bol
avec d'accord il ya une quinzaine
d'astuces de vraiment pour mémoriser des
trucs très spécifique car on peut même
créer des rappels mémorielle pour avoir
des trucs qui leur reviennent et
l'incroyable charnière de ses réels
apprendre par coeur sans vous tous c'est
génial c'est pas grâce à vous et vos
techniques mais je bête vous le prendre
je vous prendre ses
26 euros pas du tout quant à elle faire
vous allez vous reprendre parce que en
fait le prix des livres est réglé en
france va faire moins cher en touche r2
ce qu'a annoncé qu'il n'y ait pas c'est
donc moi ce que je vais faire c'est quoi
aller chez un libraire passer la part je
vais l'acheter chez nous alors je vais
passer dans le lien dans la description
ouais ya toutes les boutiques en ligne
la culture à amazon historique au pire
je veux montrer là bas peut-être même
changer la version
non c'est vous n'êtes pas pour du tout
mais vraiment ce n'est pas bon
retravailler sa fête de la manipulation
bienveillante plutôt
bonjour gascon
[Musique]
nous avons déjà parlé plusieurs fois
dans matière grise des magiciens ils
connaissent la manipulation mieux que
personne les mentalistes aussi nous
pouvons donner l'illusion d'une réalité
différente de celle que vous connaissez
soit en montant sur les données soient
en omettant de vous donner toutes les
données soient en habituant votre
cerveau à une certaine logique une
certaine habitude soit en exploitant vos
faille physique et mentale beau
programme nous avons sélectionné pour
vous deux expériences magiques qui même
si elles sont amusantes montre à quel
point nous sommes manipulable
dans cette deuxième expérience lna on va
faire deux trucs utilisent les magiciens
parce que les magiciens utilise la
manipulation alors sciemment ou pas
c'est ça qui est rigolo parfois ils
reproduisent des choses ils n'ont pas
compris pourquoi ça marchait sur le
cerveau la première chose qu'on va faire
c'est un test que j'ai vu faire par éric
leclerc magicien très très fort il faut
rendre à césar ce qui appartient à éric
leclerc
et je suis pas persuadé que ça va
fonctionner alors on va l'essayer si ça
fonctionne ça être super si ça
fonctionne pas personne ne le sera parce
que je le couperet au montage je vais te
demander s'il te plaît de mettre tes le
bout de tes pieds sur les miens comme
ceux-ci d'accord c'est une manipulation
d'illusions de sensations et c'est
vraiment très kobe traîné
tu vas mettre un doigt sur chacun de mes
yeux et je vais me concentrer sur ma
respiration
et un moment donné je comptais à 3 et à
trois cheveux pur un tout petit peu plus
fort sur mes yeux et je devrai ressentir
quelque chose dans mon ventre comme si
on mettait un petit coup sur le ventre
de
sa marche très bien dans ce sens là mais
du coup c'est très nul parce que là pour
l'instant c'est moi qui l'ait senti et
je les fais tellement de fois que je
suis un peu rodé on va essayer de le
faire sur toi si tu ne ressens rien tu
ne ment pas et tu dis j'ai rien ressenti
et ça fonctionne pas fabien la merde
c'est le dernier tournage conclure
[Rires]
je pense qu il faut qu'on soit sûr sûr
sûr plein ressentent quelque chose on
puisse te faire confiance à du thème
éternel et tu fermes les yeux et donc tu
peux les ouvrir de ce qu'on te va bien
mais tu vas te coucher
il peut faire mais je vais toucher les
yeux je vais pas bouder fort et bien
fait
j'ai pas vu et fort mais je pars comme
si
la dernière vision c'est bon que les
rouvrira pas je peux appuyer la cause
j'appuie légèrement
c'est toi qui reste bien et c'est toi
qui me dit 3
il santini tu m'as tu appelles tu m'as
tu me la fais ma tête que tu m'as fait
comme ça les calme
avec ma troisième main magique
ah oui il a vraiment senti fort ou pas
non mais pas aussi fort moi j'ai
ressenti un mois moi ça m'a fait oui ça
m'a fait ça quoi ok tu jure que c'est
vrai oui mais comme c'était j'ai
l'impression que tu m'arnaquer mais bon
qu'est avec les mains mais je ne sais
pas
maintenant j'ai vraiment senti ce que tu
penses pas que c'est la suggestion à
force de temps parler qui te fait penser
que tu en as que tu certaine quant à
toucher je suis certaine qu'en me
toucher mais si je t'avais touché
comment je l'aurais fait parce que
quelqu'un est venu de touché alors j'ai
fermé mes yeux tu as pas fait ça et avec
ton hautement même si bien sûr c'est
exactement ça qui s'est passé bravo
est en fait qui est marrant c'est de
cesser de se dire là c'est
l'impossibilité qui te fait quand même
remonter rationnellement jusqu'à un
moment trop donné trouver une solution
mais que sur sur des choses du quotidien
à partir du moment où deux fois tu as
vécu quelque chose dans un même process
la troisième fois si on change l'autre
chose date du mal à sortir du procès ce
que tu as vu les deux premières fois et
que tu t'habitues à ça et pour être très
honnête si on avait pris cinq personnes
et que j'avais fait normalement aux 5 et
après à toi ils étaient cinq personnes
avaient menti 30 ans j'ai senti un truc
tu aurais eu encore plus de mal à te
dire attends c'est impossible qu'il ait
fait ça comme ça et tu sais
jamais qui marche ok expérience de
l'expérience de slide signé l'appel
autrement l'expérience des boulettes on
va vers des petites boulettes comme ceux
ci est alors ton job toit dans la vie
c'est de savoir si je mets la boulette
dans la main gauche
ou dans la main droite
ou dans les demain mais dans les demain
il ya un indice
ça va mais c'est assez clair quand il a
vu passer la main droite ou pas oui oui
c'est vrai ok
geste numéro un thème un attentant qui a
été extrêmement riche je demande un
régal et au mois un coup je crois que
c'est ça tu crois que c'est ça alors non
pas du tout mais tu vas voir qu'au fur
et à mesure tu vas tu amélioré et est
numéro deux
je les ai vus là mais je m'explique et
c'est là où la manipulation elle
commence c'est à dire que évident que tu
l'as vu tellement se mettre ici que tu
dis il a dit que c'est un truc de
magicien donc tu commences à toto
manipulé dans ton jugement à te dire je
ne peux pas me faire confiance c'est
terrible quand même alors que vraiment
tu l'avais vu arriver attention plus
rapide tpr est rappelé que tu étais
tellement forte qu'on va le faire plus
rapidement des liens généralement pas vu
par contre là je veux
tu peux changer d'avis si tu veux
changer d'air il m'a donc on va le
refaire on va leur faire parce que nulle
part c'est donc impossible de le nulle
part c'est dans ma poche et tu devrais
de me voir la mettre dans la poche je ne
vous aime pas
ou alors dans l'âme à gauche ou dans la
main droite d'accord non mais attends
stop ne fait pas les trucs comme ça que
tu jettes bas du cou nulle part j'ai
fait ce que je devais me faire manipuler
j'ai l'impression que là
non plus on va faire avec une grosse
mais là j'ai vu que tu achetais montré
que je crois non il faut jeter tu
verrais jeter alors ça ça si je logeais
tu le verras
ça sera cool d'allemagne où dans l'âme à
droite au québec m tu l'as acheté de
nouveaux je vois que tu fais quelque
chose tu penses que c'est derrière soi
je ne sais pas mais absolument
génial c'était je vois tu jettes je
pense mais on voit où franck toi tu ne
dis pas il ya toute la merde qui est
derrière moi il ne peut pas me faire ça
ce qui se passe c'est qu'on a un angle
morte en angle mort il commence là où tu
ne le vois plus la boulette voit donc il
suffit que à bord deux tons angle mort
je met mon poignet partir du moment où
je le jette dans son angle mort en mai
que je bouge pas le bras ton cerveau
s'auto manipule encore une fois à force
de voir l'expérience se répéter et il se
dit il s'est rien passé que je n'ai pas
vu vraiment tu vois pour lui c'est
impossible et la preuve quand je le fais
là maintenant que tu connais
d'explication en tout cas tu sais que je
vais la jetée et au moment où je fais ça
je la vois pas nécessairement partir tu
vois parce qu'à chaque fois le bras si
j'avais fait un truc un peu différent du
style bouger mon bras comme ça en fait
ton cerveau il complète toujours le
mouvement donc s'il n'y a pas un
mouvement complet il n'est pas certain à
100% que ça a été jeté et en ça ça me
permet d'aborder le point que je vais
vous expliquer maintenant l'auto
manipulation
dans la première expérience j'ai
manipulé le cerveau de just lna en
l'habitude en à une situation et en
faisant en sorte que son cerveau
déduisent ensuite qu'il s'agissait de la
même situation et gentil oui par
omission en cachant une partie des
données à savoir que je ferai autre
chose dans la deuxième expérience j'ai
également menti clairement j'ai menti
sur l'ensemble des données que
j'exprimais quand ces principes de base
sont utilisés dans la vie courante on
obtient le même résultat une réalité
différente voyons maintenant comment
vous vous en sortirez face à des
manipulations rapide
[Musique]
c'est parti pour le site à bout je te
pose des questions mais en vrai ça vous
je voulais pause ok vous réfléchissez en
même temps qu'elena vous essayez de
trouver la réponse qu'on ne les trouve
pas c'est normal c'est pas un défi à
votre intelligence a prédit savoureux
voit pas le dessin ci recouvre toujours
plus qui va le prendre comme un défi de
vie personnelle
[Rires]
enigma numéro une histoire numéro il est
midi il pleut des cordes pensez-vous
qu'en attendant 60 heures vous pourrez
voir le soleil briller à nouveau dans le
ciel que de répondre oui nous vous
donnons
donc quand on sait tous qu'en 700
réponse à
on n'en sait rien c'est votre dernier
mot oui c'est votre dernier mois aussi
bien la réponse est pts et l'on puisse
qu'il fera nuit dans 60 heures ça tombe
au milieu de la nuit
restait
alors ça ça c'est un petit mentale
pareil on s'auto manipule à ce moment là
en se disant maintenant c'est trop
aléatoire je n'ai pas assez de données
et souvent on a des données qu'on
analyse pas ou peu parce que on a
l'impression de maîtriser déjà en fait
tu vois donc on se dit van où la météo
est aléatoire c'est ça m'a donné
principal de ma vie je sais que peut pas
prévoir la météo avec beaucoup d'avancé
de que de se dire est ce que quand même
y avait pas une donnée qui pourrait me
servir et bien si un hôtel à cet étage
et c'est pas mal
mais on va s'arrêter
combien de stage à l'hôtel c'est
le rez-de-chaussée est habité par quatre
personnes je pourrais te répéter toutes
les données très de chaussée quatre
personnes chaque étage suivant est
habitée par deux personnes de plus que
le précédent 4 au rez-de-chaussée 6 au
premier 8 au deuxième 10 au troisième du
toit juste retiens juste qu'il ya
toujours de plus en plus de monde plus
on monte dans les étages ma question est
la suivante quelle est la couleur non je
rigole je rigole je ne vais pas de
couleur à quel étage de l'hôtel
l'ascenseur est il appelé le plus
souvent
oui c'est une excellente réponse à la
joie c'est déjà
très bien alors là en général les
personnes répondent au septième étage
puisque c'est là où il ya le plus de
personnes et c'est l'effet inverse c'est
un autre biais en fait on se fait
manipuler par des données qu'on nous
présente volontairement mais qu'on pas
tellement d'incidence en fait parce que
même si je n'avais pas dit combien de
personnes habitait à chaque étage quoi
qu'il arrive ce sera toujours au rez de
chaussée que les tâches sera le plus ou
moins bravo elena question suivante
comment lancer une balle de tennis pour
faire en sorte qu'elles reviennent tout
seul c'est une vraie question sans céder
d'un sans céder d'horaire en tout cas
sans obliger supplément par mayroy non
ça c'est vraiment facile
ok et je tente faut vraiment la lancer
loin de soi mais comme ça au en laye en
l'air comme ça elle reviendrait tout
seul
c'est une excellente bravo bravo au fait
qu'est ce qui me fait rien c'est parce
que tu as un vrai stress dans le doute
de tes réponses alors que vraiment si tu
réfléchis ça colle à 100% à ce que j'ai
demandé il suffit de la seule dans sa en
l'air donc c'est pour ça le diront c'est
pas d'un objet -7 d'un truc simple la
gravité alors les personnes qui n'ont
pas trouvé c'est normal pourquoi parce
qu'on a du mal à penser différemment et
à partir du moment où on dit l'ansés où
on a l'habitude on de lancer devant soi
et c'est très dur en fait ça aussi c'est
une forme de manipulation du mode par
défaut du cerveau qui va prendre sa
pensée réflexes et qui va se construire
un imaginaire qui ne sont pas dans les
données de départ mais qui deviennent de
nouvelles données en fait on a du mal à
se détacher notre imaginaire promis ses
entrées pons bravo est incroyable de
bonnes réponses sur trois un chauffeur
de bus mais ce que j'adore commencé
quand elle descend une rue il passe
devant un panneau stop sans s'arrêter
dans la gauche dans une rue en sens
interdit il croise une voiture de police
elle est du mauvais côté de la rue
plante elle est pourtant la voiture de
police ne l'arrêtent pas il n'a enfreint
aucune règle de circulation comment ça
se fait
j'aurais précisé ce genre de choses si
l'été
recul entre pop in enfreint aucune règle
répète un peu je dois mettre tous tu as
un chauffeur de bus dessin une rue il
passe devant un panneau stop sans
s'arrêter mais les banquiers le gars
était absolument la galette à pied à
chauffeur de bus
servi l'état mme boulanger également un
charcutier on a tous un métier dans la
vie il ne jugeons pas je crois c'est que
votre costume à dire marche arrière je
t'ai dit j'aurais préciser s'il était à
reculons j'étais pas d'hier
soir était un mensonge de ma part alors
ça c'est une manipulation qu'on voit
souvent par exemple dans les médias ou
aussi certains trucs politique quand on
veut faire induire quelque chose dans la
tête d'une personne on va de nous des
données qui n'a aucun intérêt mais qui
transforme un peu la vision tout ça
chaque données inutiles à une intention
cachée qu'elle soit volontaire ou pas tu
vois là une à la une intention de
tromperie et c'est le cas pour le
chauffeur de bus le fait que je te
précise salord qui a pas d'intérêt c'est
bien que je veux induire en erreur là
dedans en ce fait le dernier qui est pas
le plus compliqué un homme noir habillé
avec des vêtements complètement noir et
une cagoule noire
traverse lentement une route au même
moment une limousine noire qui roulent
tous feux éteints débouche d'un virage à
toute allure la collision en semble
inévitable et pourtant le chauffeur
parvint à l'éviter à la dernière seconde
comme motif
de répondre sincèrement qu'il n'y a pas
de lui
le chauffeur
[Rires]
un homme noir habillé avec des vêtements
noirs et une cagoule noire traverse
lentement une route au même moment une
limousine noire qui roule pourtant tous
feux éteints débouche d'un virage à
toute allure la collision semble
inévitable et je viens sur tous les
jours pourquoi lui et ses phares
c'est la même mécanique que celui
d'avant vraiment la même mécanique et
c'est pareil pour montrer la
manipulation avec une donnée qui ne sert
à rien ça change tout ton raisonnement
en fait état encore eu un imaginaire
différend avec
machin parce que j'ai précisé quelque
chose l'absence de quelque chose en fait
c'est hyper intéressant je trouve sur
ces petites énigmes qu'on voit à quel
point on est manipulable chavatte
service
rapide je serai bien adam brown s'était
très bien moi votre tableau 10 gt
applaudi des deux mains
[Applaudissements]
ces questions anodines montre comment
nous pouvons nous faire vite manipuler
en ajoutant des informations qui oriente
le raisonnement alors qu'elles ne sont
pas utiles par exemple c'est le principe
de la petite graine si je vous dit un
commerçant s'est fait cambriolé cette
semaine c'est une information si je vous
dit un commerçant s'est fait cambriolé
cette semaine parra migrants alors j'ai
une volonté manipulatrice de faire des
conclusions mental sur les origines du
cambrioleur vous pourriez me dire oui
mais c'est factuel dans ce cas pourquoi
ne pas dire un commerçant s'est fait
cambriolé cette semaine par un homme aux
chaussures bleues qui mesurait un mètre
80 la manipulation mentale passe donc
dans le mensonge limpide ou par omission
mais aussi dans la volonté de préciser
des détails plutôt que d'autres pour
amener le manipuler à faire lui même les
mauvaises conclusions c'est comme dans
le film inception
beaucoup plus puissant car ensuite ça
devient l'opinion du manipulé
[Musique]
j'ai déjà utilisé ce terme étrange au
début de l'épisode si nous nous
manipulons tous si on veut bien
l'admettre évidemment alors comment
faire pour ne pas être un manipulateur
malhonnête malgré nous il existe des
solutions simples intégré à notre
manière de communiquer nous allons en
voir plusieurs maintenant
alors exceptionnellement l'expérience 4
n'en est pas une ça va être une
discussion par les manipulations honnête
de manipulation tout court et de
plusieurs choses il y en a peut-être que
tu connais ou pas et j'avais envie d'en
discuter avec quelqu'un et je me suis
pourquoi pas toi parce que tu es là
c'est assez pratique une des plus
grandes manipulations convient nous
mêmes et qu'on s'inflige à nous mêmes
c'est qu'on ne sait pas quelque chose et
qu'on émet un avis dessus en gros si je
te demande par exemple est ce que tu
penses que la 5g c'est une bonne chose
ou une mauvaise chose pour la santé est
ce que toi tu as un avis dessus
sincèrement
pourtant si on tue pose cette question
ce soir dans une soirée avec des amis es
tu veux leur dire non mais la 5g quand
même c'est pas très bon pour la santé tu
vas voir tout de suite deux clans se
former ceux qui sont pour et ceux qui
sont contre et très peu de personnes
auront le recul de faire comme toi non
je n'ai pas d'avis parce que j'ai pas
les données parce que je ne sais pas et
c'est un nom ça ça s'appelle l'effet de
denning kruger tu connais ou pas ouais
on peut en parler vite fait tu peux le
commenter alors peut-être même voici les
faits dany krueger qui montre que moi on
connaît un sujet plus on en parle avec
confiance et fermeté alors ça c'est le
tableau le plus connu avec eux quand je
ne sais rien sur le sujet je suis de la
montagne de la stupidité
parce que je me suis reste hymne
énormément ensuite quand j'apprends
beaucoup sur le sujet je suis dans la
vallée de l'humilité parce que je
comprends que je ne sais pas grand chose
et qui masque beaucoup de chemin à
parcourir et après je vais sur le
plateau de la consolidation quand un
petit peu expert de mon sujet pourquoi
ça sert énormément la manipulation parce
que des manipulateurs connaissent très
bien ce fonctionnement et donc ils vont
tous obligés à émettre un avis assez
rapidement et après tu vas tu accroché à
ton avis tu vois ce que je veux et tu va
plus lâcher et si je te fais avoir la
vie qui m'arrange pour prendre une
décision un peu plus tard qui m'arrange
bah en fait c'est une manipulation dès
le départ donc un bon truc pour pas se
faire manipuler c'est savoir dire je ne
sais pas et avoir beaucoup d'humilité
par rapport à son propre savoir si j'ai
besoin de temps que les
comédiens peu l'effet des croqueurs quoi
oui mais j'ai l'impression que quand tu
dis que tu t'intéresses à un sujet qu en
tête quand tu atterris c'est un minimum
d'expérience c'est là qu'il y avait un
souci mais visiblement quand tu
commences à mieux connaître le sujet
oui en fait en réalité c'est ça c'est
que dès que tu aimais un avis sur un
sujet que tu connais très mal telle
confiance exacerbée par contre dès que
tu commences à engranger les premières
connaissances juste les premières c'est
là où tu as beaucoup moins de confiance
quand tu en parles tu vois d'ailleurs le
truc le plus intéressant je trouve sur
l'effet de nine kruger c'est que on
mobile effet denning kruger à partir du
moment où on parle de l'effet de ning
kruger dire que là je t'en parle avec
confiance mais je me connais pas plus
que ça en effet dunning kruger tu vois
qu attention à ça le deuxième chose et
je crois que tu ne connais pas du coup
c'est le triangle des cartman très
important dans la manipulation tel fait
découvrir tu me pose toutes les
questions que tu veux parce que là pour
le coup c'est toujours rené broc
victimes
exactement ça le triangle dramatique de
quatre semaines je suis persécuteurs
sauveur aux victimes dont il ya aucun
des trois rôles qui est correct à partir
du moment où tu es dans ce triangle là
ça se passe mal pour toi une victime va
avoir besoin d'un persécuteurs le
persécuteur va avoir besoin d'une
victime le sauveur pour exister a besoin
d'une victime et c'est le sauveur il est
souvent sauveur d'ailleurs par manque de
données et par problèmes personnels à
régler que si là je fais quelque chose
pour toi je vois que tu as du mal avec
ta montre par exemple tu vois je te
prends ta monde pour que la règle et je
te transforme quand même en victime
instantanément tu vois et si toi tu me
dis pardon mais j'avais pas besoin de
toi je fais rabat super c'est comme ça
que tu me dis merci et je vais me
transformer en victime et je le
transforme en un persécuteur donc le
triangle de de cartman on passe d'un
rôle à l'autre très facilement ça c'est
un très bon outil pour les manipulateurs
d'essayer de te faire rentrer dans
cercle à partir du moment où tu es dans
cercle là c'est très dur d'en sortir en
fait c'est la volonté d'une seule
personne d'en sortir et dès que tu sens
que quelqu'un va te mettre dans un rôle
de victime ou de persécuteur août
sauveur c'est pas bon du tout quoi c'est
une manipulation tout de suite
exactement c'est très dur d'en sortir
parce qu'on a envie de se justifier
surtout ne pas alimenter ce triangle là
qui est dans les manipulations social du
quotidien c'est quand même énormément
utilisé et c'est utiliser aussi à grande
échelle à l'échelle des foules
d'ailleurs que à un gouvernement entier
peut dire je suis obligée d'appliquer
telle mesure parce que vous n'avez pas
fait ce qu'il faut on l'a vraiment
l'imposant que je parle du coc vide mais
pas du tout mais ça s'applique quand
même à beaucoup de choses et on peut le
faire un peuple entier donc c'est très
important de connaître ça donc tu
connaissais tu avais déjà entendu parler
et dans la manipulation honnête ou
malhonnête
il ya deux autres choses dont on
pourrait voir assez rapidement qui est
la demande implicite si vous voulez être
honnête dans votre vie ne fait pas de
demande implicite demande implicite
s'est il fait un peu chaud là je
continue par les
lra moment donné quelqu'un va arrêter
son travail il valait m'ouvrir la
fenêtre pour qu'ils fassent plus frais
et ses terrains et qui le courant d'air
va faire tomber mes cartons qui a
derrière gmt un puncheur à caf m
peut-être que loïc aura ouvert la
fenêtre va me dire oui mais c'est comme
il faisait chaud tu voulais que je
voulais cogérant demandez moi
personnellement j'ai juste dit qu'il
faisait chaud donc en fait c'est
terrible la demande implicite parce que
tu gardes le pouvoir en plus tu peut
tout reprocher à l'autre et tu lui de
voir rien quoi tu vois il ya deux choses
à faire si toi tu entends une demande
implicite ne pas la comprendre et si tu
sens que tu vas en faire une c2 bien
formulé la demande pour ne jamais faire
de demande implicite elles sont été
prises
et le centre d'intérêt de tout de tout
ce blabla c'est de protéger le libre
arbitre en fait en permanence c'est vrai
que c'est intéressant parce que avant
youtube j'étais à 100 et c'est vrai que
j'ai été beaucoup confronté à les gens
qui utilisaient beaucoup la manipulation
c'est vrai que c'est très plaisant à
voir quoi toi tu le voyais ou sais pas
ce que disent et ce qu'ils allaient
faire non non je voyais que je voyais et
du coup c'est un peu c'est vrai que
c'est très compliqué cesser les
anciennes techniques de management son
toit 13 septembre dos plutôt qu'un
leader c'est plutôt les choses devraient
dans le milieu du riz thé louge et est
encore fort comme ça c'était difficile à
voir quoi même ce que vous avez des
employés de collaborateurs nous c'était
les employés mais chez décathlon maladie
parce que j'ai déjà été quatre mois ce
que je pense que décathlon j'ai fait mes
bureaux d'étudiants là bas et là c'est
déjà collaborateur il y est déjà disons
même projet en fait mes collaborateurs
et pas une bonne terminologie qui trouve
pas non maintenant pour un employé non
en fait un collaborateur en fait on lui
induit l'idée qu'on collabore pour un
but commun du coup les heures ne conte
pas tellement parce que c'est quand même
notre projet en fait mais en vrai le mot
employé reste intéressant parce que ça
veut dire qu'il ya un employeur et
l'emploi pour faire une tâche et pas une
autre que cette personne elle vient
percer clash entre un sincère et contre
un salaire et donc pas faire tout et
n'importe quoi non plus et cette fausse
valorisation de collaborateurs tu vois
on ensemble même bateau tu crois pas que
c'est juste pour caler avec la
génération y ou z qui sont en quête de
sens et terrain pour les relire un
projet ce que c'est pas ouais mais pour
les rallier à un projet qu'il faut
donc si si bien sûr que ça fait sens ça
attire aussi les personnes et les
nouvelles générations qui sont en quête
de sens marbre et le taf recio même donc
il n'a pas plus de sens intime derrière
c'est là où ces problématiques ça change
la forme n'en change pas le fond c'est
intéressant
pour en savoir plus sur le triangle de
cartman je vous invite à regarder une de
mes anciennes vidéos que je vous
mettrais évidemment dans la description
merci à tous les participants à toute
l'équipe à charles x man united à la
production à loïc à la réal avec toute
son équipe bien sûr et à just lna
n'hésitez pas à découvrir ces vidéos le
lien est dans la description sa soeur le
dimanche c'est très très drôle le
prochain épisode de matière grise sera
le mois prochain il va parler du langage
et de ses secrets et de ses formes vous
pouvez vous abonner gratuitement à la
chaîne si cette série vous plaît
évidemment c'est pas une manipulation et
vous avez également laissé aux autres
épisodes précédents de matière grise
dans la description il ya de quoi
regarder alors pensez vous pouvoir
devenir des manipulateurs bienveillant
est ce que vous êtes vraiment capable de
détecter les manipulations malveillantes
dans votre quotidien existe il des
techniques de manipulation des foules
pour manipuler toute une population
entièrement vous serez tout cela et bien
plus dans les prochains épisodes de
matière grise à très bientôt ciao
sympa ce livre
[Musique]